Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Hast du auch einen Meteorschauer irgendwie abgekriegt?
Hab ich überhaupt nicht mitbekommen alles und die Videos dazu sind ja jetzt auch bei YouTube gesperrt.
Hab ich nicht mitbekommen. Nein. Ja, auch wenn die Meteore über der Erde eintauchen und Rundglück über Landstriche bringen.
Russland, ne?
Jaja, Russland.
Wie viele haben die getroffen, die Dinger? 20 verletzt oder so, ne?
Ne, mehr. Ja, also tausend oder so. Na, da ist eine komplette Stadt ist da entglast worden. Es war einfach mal so eine Detonation mit irgendwie zehnfache Hiroshima-Power. Also jetzt nicht mit Verstrahlung und so, sondern so die Druckwelle, also diese Energie, die ja frei geworden ist. Nur das befand sich halt in 20 Kilometer Höhe und war von daher jetzt nicht ganz so desaströs. Wäre das Ding aber ja etwas größer gewesen und wäre es etwas später detoniert, da hätte es schon ganz anders aussehen können. Also wäre das Ding irgendwie in 10 Kilometer Höhe explodiert und hätte noch vielleicht ein paar Meter mehr auf den Hüften gehabt, so im Durchmesser, dann wären da die Häuser platt gewesen, aber locker. Das ist sozusagen die einzige wirkliche, die einzige denkbare Naturkatastrophe, die in der Lage ist, die komplette Menschheit auf einmal zu vernichten. So ist es. Und wir reden über Netzpolitik. Lass uns lieber über die letzte Sendung reden, denn da war auch nie alles richtig, oder?
Nee, da gab es wichtige Hinweise. Also es gab einen sehr wichtigen Hinweis, den ich Herrn Bernd Neumann gar nicht abschließend vorgestellt habe. Denn besonderen Ruhm erlangte er bereits letztes Jahr, glaube ich, oder sogar 2011.
Unser Kulturscheißminister.
Genau, der erlangte nämlich Ehre und Ruhm bei der CDU-Media-Neid. Das war irgendwie so eine Internetveranstaltung von der CDU. Da hat dann Angela Merkel auch gesagt, dass sie mit dem Internet wichtig ist. Und von extra drei Randen da eine Reporterin rum, eine Satiresendung, stellte den Leuten allerlei Fragen. Und die schönsten Fragen hat er bekommen und hat auch die besten Antworten darauf gehabt. Wir verlinken das mal und wer es noch nicht kennt, der wird sich freuen über die Antwort von Bernd Neumann, was denn zu tun ist, wenn das Internet voll ist. Ja, das ist also auf jeden Fall ein Must-Click quasi und dann hat sich meine angedeutete Verschwörungstheorie bestätigt, dass das Per-Block gar nicht unter Hackerangriffen zu leiden hatte. Gegenüber dem Magazin Media meldete sich dann nämlich jemand von Strato und als großer Hosting-Provider hat Strato natürlich entsprechende Detection, Intrusendetection, Hardware und Strato. Ja, natürlich. Da geht einfach eine Lampe an, wenn da irgendwie was unter Beschuss ist. Die filtern natürlich auch automatische DDoS-Attacken oder einfach zu erkennbare DDoS-Attacken, filtern sie und sagen, also weder hat unser Alarmsystem angeschlagen, was schon mal was heißt, noch hat uns jemand um Hilfe gebeten, weil wir selbstverständlich die Möglichkeit haben, so eine Seite im Netz zu halten. Also das Ding hat offensichtlich auch wahrscheinlich auf irgendeinem Webspace oder so gelegen. Die gehen eh erst mal so schnell nicht in die Knie, weil Strato als Hosting Provider natürlich schon darauf achtet, dass sie das da ordentlich balancen oder so. Also Strato sagt...
Was wollt ihr eigentlich? Also mit anderen Worten, die haben sich das alles ausgedacht, aber es gab doch dann auch so eine Gruppe, die sich sozusagen selbst auf die Schultern geklopft hat dafür.
Ja, also ich würde mal sagen, also um heutzutage so einen Strato-Platz zu machen, wenn das da so ein Scherthost ist, ich weiß gar nicht genau, worauf das gehorstet wurde, aber Strato auf jeden Fall sagt, wir haben nichts mitbekommen und man würde schon davon ausgehen, dass sie mit ihren IDS sowas merken. Und die sagen also, haben wir nichts von mitbekommen.
Also macht in zunehmendem Maße so den Eindruck, als ob diese ganze Aktion eigentlich auch netzpolitisch vollkommen uninteressant ist und tatsächlich eigentlich eher so ein politischer Vorfall ist, dass sie da irgendwie gemerkt haben, dass mit diesem, ja, wir nennen die Spender nicht, dingen sie sich unter Umständen da einen Straftatbestand für den Kanzlerkandidaten der SPD einfangen und dann lieber schnell mal weg, so, ah, da haben wir jetzt gerade hier mal so ein paar komische Logins, da bauschen wir mal ordentlich auf und dann ist auch wieder alles weg.
Metronaut hatte, glaube ich, auch die im Rahmen einer anderen, eines anderen SMS-Austausch, was der auch in den Medien war, einen theoretischen Austausch zwischen Steinbrück und Steinkühler, ne, Steinbrück heißt der, ne, ja, geleakt, indem dann also gesagt wurde, die kommen mir hier, Wege, du machst es jetzt weg, also, keine Ahnung, verlinken wir auch nochmal.
Habt keinen Bock, dass du alles an die Wand fährst?
Ja, irgendwie sowas, ne. Ich lasse doch von dir nicht meine, meine Kampagne kaputt machen. Genau, sowas in der Art war das, ich suche das nochmal raus.
Ist auch wirklich ein schönes Mem, ne?
Ein wunderschönes Mem.
Ich glaube, das wird halten.
So, dann wurden wir dann auch in den Kommentaren noch darauf hingewiesen, dass es zu dem Steingüter nämlich auch eine Vorgeschichte gibt. Und zwar stand er in dem Verdacht während des Landtagwahlkampfs 2009 auf dem Blog wir in NRW irgendwie interne Papiere und E-Mails, also Landtagswahl NRW, ja, da irgendwie gegen die NRW CDU gefeuert zu haben und außerdem dann in Folge so die Verschwörungstheorie oder der Verdacht, dass er dann nach der gewonnenen Wahl lukrative Aufträge von der SPD für diese Agentur da bekommen hat, mit der er dann glaube ich auch diese Seite da gemacht hat. Also der hat, Steinkühler hat wohl offensichtlich schon mal für die SPD gevloggt, ohne Namen dran, so oft anscheinend die Geschichte. Ich weiß nicht, Steinbrück und Steinkühler ist super, das reicht.
Hier gibt es ja so auch verschiedenste.
So gut ist der gar nicht. Es gibt mehr, ist ja unglaublich. Steinkühler minus Kommen ist das, das ist er dann glaube ich. Gut, jetzt gucken wir mal hier. Team Karl Heinz, kann das sein? Nicht, dass ich jetzt hier irgendwie völlig anahm.
Klar kann das sein, aber nenne dich nicht Karl Heinz. Also Steinkühler scheint es auch gerade in der SPD eine Menge zu geben.
Nicht, dass wir jetzt hier den falschen Steinkühler. Ja doch, Karl-Heinz-Steinkühler. Mit gesichtslosen Geldströmen kennt sich. Karl-Heinz-Steinkühler ausschreibt der Westen das Portal der Watz Mediengruppe. Also das noch als Nachtrag dazu. Dann gibt es eine Fazitik, die habe ich dazu verlinkt.
Gut, dann hätten wir das auch geklärt. Das war es so mit unserem Nachtrag. Weitere Lab-Seasons sind uns nicht untergekommen.
Ich glaube jetzt nicht, bisher noch nicht gemeldet.
Schauen wir mal, was das BKA so treibt. Die beschäftigen sich ja auch mit dem Internet. Das ist ja auch ein modernes Aufklärungsunternehmen und weiß eigentlich immer Bescheid. Die müssen ja eigentlich auch das Internet schon vor uns gesehen haben, schon 30 Jahre vorher eigentlich.
Die haben das völlig raus. Sie sind ja auch Visionär. Und da gab es jetzt eine ganze Zitate-Sammlung, die angefallen ist beim Europäischen Polizeikongress, der hier in Berlin stattgefunden hat. Der Polizeikongress ist so eine Überwachungs- und Sicherheitsveranstaltung. Ich weiß da gar nicht so genau, was genau das Ziel ist. Es ist die europasführende Veranstaltung zur inneren Sicherheit und hat dieses Jahr stattgefunden und hat den Schutz und Sicherheit im digitalen Raum. Es gibt dann sogar eine Art Watch-Blog für, das habe ich auch mal verlinkt. Da kommen sie dann alle hin und sagen, wie fürchterlich das ist und was wir alles noch überwachen müssen. Unter anderem dann eben der Innenminister von Nordrhein-Westfalen, Ralf Jäger, der dann da sich wohl auf die Bühne stellt und sagt, also dieses Verhalten der Justizministerin Sabine Lauthäuser-Schnachenberger, die da die ganze Zeit die Vorratsdatenspeicherung versucht zu blockieren, das sei also nah an einer Strafvereidlung. Also man kann sich vorstellen, was das für eine Veranstaltung ist, wo einer auf der Bühne steht und solche Sprüche kloppt. Wenn ich mich nicht täusche, Fanzi, findet sie in dem gleichen Gebäude statt, wie bis zum vorletzten Jahr auch der Chaos-Communication-Kongress.
Es ist offensichtlich nicht so eine populäre, nicht so eine gut besuchte Veranstaltung, der Polizeikongress.
Die ziehen auch bald nach Hamburg. Gab es da nicht vor ein paar Jahren mal irgendwie viel Wind um das Gerücht, das da gestreut wurde, dass nämlich der CCC im Rahmen seines Kongresses das BCC verwanzt hätte, um den Polizeikongress abzuhören?
Ja, es war so, dass Andreas Burg sich dort legitim angemeldet und eingeschrieben hat auf der Veranstaltung, um dort teilzunehmen im Rahmen seiner Tätigkeit als Sicherheitsberater, der auch mit sensitiven Behörden und was weiß ich allem zu tun hat, also vollkommen legitimes Anrecht hatte, dort teilzunehmen. Dann aber vor Ort von den Veranstaltern da irgendwie am Eingang rausgesiebt wurde, so nach dem Motto, die sind doch bei diesem schmierigen Hackerverein und die haben doch hier bestimmt alles verwanzt und sie gefährden hier die innere Sicherheit, sozusagen auf dieser Veranstaltung, wo über die innere Sicherheit diskutiert wird. Und dann wurde er dann wieder herauskomplimentiert, obwohl er halt regulär ein Ticket erworben hat und da auch, weißt du, nicht als CCC auftrat und so. Das ist dann im Nachgang hochgespült worden und da wurde dann auch seitens, wie soll ich sagen, politischer Kreise auch ein sehr nachdrückliches Rolls-Bann zu verstehen gegeben. Und das war dann allen Beteiligten auch furchtbar peinlich und tut uns sehr leid. Und das kommt ja auch nicht wieder vor und pipapo. Aber man zeigt schon so ein bisschen, wie da die Paranoia doch irgendwie auch ausgeprägt ist. Ich weiß nicht, inwiefern das jetzt irgendwas Systemisches erklärt oder inwiefern da jetzt nur ein Einzelner komplett frei gedreht hat und nicht mehr klarkam. I don't know.
Also ich weiß, eigentlich habe ich jedes Jahr jemanden aus meinem Bekanntenkreis gehabt, der da mal hingegangen ist zur Feindbeobachtung. Das wäre ein ganz besonderes Gutschein, das nicht zu machen.
Ja, ich meine, man kann jetzt natürlich auch hier mit viel Suffizanz das Ganze kommentieren. Wir sind ja auch nicht vollständig ironiefrei. Nur, ich finde das ja jetzt auch erstmal keinen Fehler. Also ich meine, dass die Polizei sich über die Bedrohungsszenarien im Netz austauscht und unterhält, ist ja vollkommen legitim und ist ja auch nicht so, dass es da nicht eine Menge Dinge gibt, auf die sie ihr Augenmerk auch sehr wohl richten sollten. Dass sich jetzt hier unter anderem auch Grundeinstellungen zur Strafrechtsverfolgung finden, die, sagen wir mal jetzt so mit unserem Grundansatz, nicht unbedingt kongruent sind, das ist ja auch keine Neuigkeit. Von daher halte ich es auch für vollkommen legitim, dass man an solchen Kongressen auch teilnimmt, gegebenenfalls auch mitredet und dort auch andere Kräfte mal zur Sprache kommen lassen soll. Inwiefern das im Rahmen dieses Kongresses überhaupt möglich ist, kann ich dir ehrlich gesagt nicht sagen. Ich war da noch nicht, außer dass da so ein BCC stattfindet, weiß ich da jetzt wenig. Obwohl die jetzt wahrscheinlich die Ersten sind, die diese geile neue Leinwand da ausprobiert haben, dieses BCC da gerade irgendwie. Die haben da nämlich wirklich jetzt so ein riesen 2K HD Großbildleinwand.
Wir müssen mal wieder mehr über den Polizeikongress reden. Vor Ort war Jürgen Maurer, BKA Vizepräsident. Und der sagte dann was sehr, sehr Spannendes. Er sagte also, egal wie man über die Vorratsdatenspeicherung diskutiert, man muss sich hier entscheiden, ob man den Ermittlungserfolg will oder nicht. Also wir erkennen genau wieder diese, das ist ja seit Jahren die Argumentation.
Ohne Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist einfach eine Aufklärung aber nicht möglich.
Ist einfach nicht möglich. Und er sagt dann, und das ist sehr spannend, da reiht er sich also ein mit anderen Visionären, wer im Internet ist, hat den Privatraum verlassen und befindet sich quasi im öffentlichen Raum. Das Internet ist per se der öffentliche Raum und entsprechend geht darin keine Privatsphäre und deswegen sei auch jedes Datum dort dem BKA im Rahmen seiner Fahndungen zugänglich zu machen. Das gelte, so wie es jetzt die Medien seine Worte da und seine Interpretation wiedergeben, eben dann auch für halböffentliche bzw. nichtöffentliche Teile. Zum Beispiel die IP-Adresse, die man beim Besuch einer Seite hinterlässt oder eben Dinge, die man in ein soziales Netzwerk einspeist, auch wenn man sie da per Einstellung nur einer Teilöffentlichkeit wiedergibt. Es ist ganz klar, dass das Bundesverfassungsgericht das ein bisschen anders sieht. Wir haben da ja die einschlägigen Urteile, die also sagen, Bürgerrechte gelten genauso bei der Kommunikation per Computer. Ich glaube, der Netzbegriff ist da auch ein bisschen sehr unscharf. Also die Behauptung, dass etwas, was ich einem bestimmten Server anvertraue, mittels dieses Netzes, vielleicht sogar über eine verschlüsselte HTTP-Verbindung, das per se dann wiederum als öffentlich zu definieren, ist gewagt. Aber okay, das muss man jetzt auch gar nicht so im Detail auseinandernehmen. Interessant war dann, dass die Spackeria sich dazu äußerte und sagte, der Mann hat Recht und quasi sich darauf fokussiert, dass es im Internet keinen Privatraum gäbe. Das Fazit, den Herr Maurer hat einen für viele unangenehmen Schluss aus den technischen Gegebenheiten gezogen, ihn dafür anzugreifen, dass er die Technologie verstanden hat, ist falsch. Das Fazit der Spackeria, da muss ich also auf Scherste widersprechen. Insbesondere denke ich nicht, dass das die technischen Gegebenheiten widerspiegelt, was er da schildert. Da muss man denke ich schon einen Unterschied setzen zwischen einem Netz und dem einzelnen Computer in diesem Netz.
Ja, die eigene Infrastruktur insbesondere, die ja nun, wie das Verfassungsgericht ja auch vor kurzem erst nochmal richtig hervorgehoben hat, also wie ich finde, mit dem Grundrecht auf die Unversehrtheit, auf die eigene Infrastruktur. Nur weil die jetzt am Internet ist, ist ja noch nicht per se öffentlich.
Also ich habe Geräte, die sind per se am Internet. Das wäre fürchterlich. Also ich betrachte meine Computer als Teil des Internets.
Ich meine, mit der Logik wäre ja auch ein privates Telefongespräch öffentlich, weil es sich durch ein öffentliches Netz bewegt. Die Forderung hat glaube ich bisher auch noch keiner erhoben.
Ja, zumindest die Behauptung nicht, dass das BKA die Inhalte haben möchte. Aber diese diese Schmackeria, Privatsphäre, Argumentation, dann da bei einem BKA-Vize zu sehen, ist interessant. Naja, im Rahmen der Debatte, also was er dann auch noch so sagt, das ist dann auch sehr schön, um nochmal zum 100. Mal, ich will das jetzt gar nicht so lange vertiefen, diese Argumentation auch zu zeigen. Also er sagt, ja, das ist alles ganz fürchterlich, wir können das alles gar nicht aufklären. Und dann sagt er, beim Cybercrime haben wir das Dunkelfeldproblem. Also er sagt, das Cybercrime ist alles ganz schlimm. Und zwar wurden in Deutschland irgendwie im Jahr 2011 60.000 Fälle registriert. Wir haben aber überhaupt keine Möglichkeit, die Ausmaße des Dunkelfeldes auch nur in Umrissen zu erahnen.
Das Dunkelfeldes?
Ja, mit anderen Worten. Wir haben keinerlei Indikator für ein Dunkelfeld. Deswegen heißt es Dunkelfeld. Also muss das riesengroß sein, weil wir können es ja gar nicht erfassen.
Das ist so wie dunkle Materie. Wir wissen, dass es da ist, aber wir können es nicht sehen.
Also muss das unglaublich viel sein.
Und es ist unheimlich viel.
Also so, völliger Quatsch. Prognosen zur zukünftigen Entwicklung sein, also schwierig. Man sieht so diese unbekannte, die Gefahr unbekannten, die unbekannte Gefahr unbekannten Ausmaßes, die er da nennt. Und dann sagt er... Ja, genau. Das ist natürlich die größte Furcht des Kriminalvizes, BKA-Vize. Und dann warnt er zum Beispiel vor der Twitter-Drive-by-Infektion. Also klassisch, jeden Tag fangen sich Tausende von Leuten auf Twitter-Viren ein, weil sie auf einen falschen Link klicken. Das ist jetzt so das Angriffsszenario, was er da an die Wand malt. Deckt sich jetzt mit meiner Erfahrung nicht unbedingt.
Ich hatte das auch schon vor ein paar Tagen.
Eine Drive-by-Infektion via Twitter?
Ja, und zwar, also ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt das ist, was er anspricht und ob das jetzt das ist, was irgendwie als verbreitet gilt. Aber ich hatte bei verschiedenen Leuten, die mir folgen oder denen ich folge, sprich, die mir direkt Nachrichten schicken können, kam immer so dieselbe Nachricht mit, LOL, do you know this picture of you, Link.
Ah, die habe ich auch bekommen, ja.
Und hast du auch draufgelegt? So, das hatte ich bei zwei oder drei Leuten.
Und dahinter verbarg sich dann wahrscheinlich ein PDF oder was?
Ja, ich bin dem Link dann, also ich weiß nicht mehr genau, ich war glaube ich in der Situation auch irgendwie mobil und konnte gerade nicht wirklich jetzt da eine Analyse fahren, aber es war halt dann doch zu offensichtlich, dass wir auf einmal der Deutsche auf Englisch schreiben, der alte Witz. Dann eine Französin hat das dann auch nochmal betroffen, also genau drei Fälle, dreimal dieselbe Nachricht. Aber sowas gibt es sicherlich schon, aber das ist jetzt im Wesentlichen kein Twitter-Problem, sondern das Problem ist halt, Leute, deren Rechner gehackt werden oder deren Twitter-Passwort in irgendeiner Form.
Also klassisch, das ist ein klassischer Angriff. Natürlich auch über Twitter kann ich Leuten links zu in der Regel infizierten PDF-Dokumenten schicken.
Twitter verleitet natürlich noch ein bisschen mehr dazu, da einfach mal so eben draufzuklicken, ohne sich viel Gedanken darum zu machen, das übliche Spiel.
Also auf jeden Fall, das ist also alles ganz gefährlich und deswegen muss das alles überwacht werden. Und im Rahmen wurde dann bekannt, dass der Europäische Gerichtshof im Januar die Fristverlängerung zur deutschen Antwort bei diesem Verfahren gegen Deutschland, weil Deutschland die Vorratsdatenspeicherung noch nicht durchführt, nicht angenommen hat. Das heißt, Deutschland muss bis zum 25. Februar im Rahmen dieses Verfahrens seine Antwort vorbringen. Das heißt, da wird sich noch mal was tun auf der europäischen Ebene. Was also die Vorratsdatenspeicherung?
25.
Februar.
Das ist schon relativ bald. Wir haben gerade den 21. Also das heißt, da zeichnet sich ab, dass Vorratsdatenspeicherungsdebatten auf Europaebene dann bald wieder weitergeführt werden. Viel Spaß.
Das hatten wir jetzt auch schon lange nicht mehr.
Ja, das war's. Ich denke schon, ja. Wer sich noch mehr für den Polizeikongress interessiert, dem sei dann die Linksammlung empfohlen.
Gut, bleiben wir im Behördenbereich. Da fällt ja auch so einiges an und vor.
Ja, da gab es wieder ein DEDOS, ne?
Ist das jetzt so lustig? Wurde die Behörde dann auch gleich eingestellt?
Es ging das Open Data Portal Deutschland an den Start. govdata.de Oder Datendeutschland oder sowas heißt die URL.
Datendeutschland?
Ich hab das irgendwie, ich bin da immer ganz wuschig, wenn da so viele Deutschland drin vorkommt. Weil da gibt es auch eine Deutschlandlizenz und so. Alles ganz wirr. Also govdata.de ging online und war dann auch sofort wieder offline. Aber dazu kommen wir gleich. Hintergrund der Sache ist, dass es natürlich sehr viele Daten gibt, die bei Behörden anfallen. Und dass die relativ klar auch nach Gesetzeslage eigentlich ein öffentliches Gut sind. Sie sind von dem Geld der Steuerzahler bezahlt oder deren Erfassung wurde bezahlt. Sie betreffen die Bürger und können natürlich so für Recherchen im Journalismus und für, weiß ich nicht, für alle möglichen politischen Handlungen durchaus von Interesse sein. Und einem der Artikel, die ich dazu las, wurde dann so schön gesagt, Transparenz kann die Mitbestimmung fördern und die Korruption verringern. Wir erinnern uns an die Argumentation der Open-Data-Aktivisten, die wir auch hier schon zu Gast hatten. Seit 2006 haben wir das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, mit dessen Hilfe Bürger ohne Begründung bestimmte Daten einfordern können und den Behörden dann eigentlich nur die Möglichkeit bleibt, diese Daten auch tatsächlich rauszurücken. Oder sich auf eine der vielfältigen Ausnahmeregelungen zu berufen, um die Daten dann nicht rauszugeben.
Oder einfach hohe Preise zu fordern.
Genau, oder Kosten anzugeben oder so. Mit GovData will die Bundesregierung einen Schritt in diese Richtung gehen, da so eine zentrale Stelle zu haben. Wo man also direkt Daten veröffentlicht und nicht erst auf Anfrage. Eigentlich eine feine Sache.
Aber wer nutzt das?
Ja, das wird man dann sehen.
Also ich meine, wer bietet dort Daten an?
Ja, kann ich dir zeigen. Gehst du auf diese Webseite und dann siehst du, dass es relativ unstrukturiert ist, also wie gesagt zum Launch waren das 1000 Datensätze oder mehr, 10.000 wahrscheinlich oder was? Eine relativ hohe Zahl, wie auch immer.
Datensätze.
Ja, genau. Dann kannst du dir so sagen, okay hier, ich guck mal hier in der Bevölkerung, Abfallentsorgung in Deutschland, Jahre und Anlagenart. Ja, komisch. So, gucken wir uns mal an. Wie kann ich das jetzt runterladen? So, das ist zur freien Nutzung. Oh je, jetzt ist das schon wieder dieser Link auf diese Deutschland-Lizenz.
Also das ist eine Aktion des Bundesministeriums des Innern.
Jaja, das vom Innenministerium.
Also das ist unsere Creative Commons-Lizenz.
Ne, diese Informationen, aber nicht alles. Also sie haben ja nämlich eine eigene Lizenz dafür. Das ist ja dann, da kommen wir ja dann zur Kritik.
Achso, diese Hintergrundinformationen, auf die ich schaue.
Ja, die hatte, die ist jetzt gerade mal so eine Art Pressrelease. Die haben eine Pressemitteilung unter Creative Commons gestellt. Das ist sehr nett von ihnen.
Ja, das war schon mal ein Anfang.
Also man sieht jetzt hier irgendwie, welche Deponien und welche Abfallentsorgungsanlagen, Input, Pipapo, Abfälle, wie viele Tonnen sie da irgendwie vernichtet haben. Also irgendeine schöne Statistik weiß der Geier. Wer sich mit Abfallentsorgungen beschäftigt, für den ist das sicherlich irgendwann mal von Interesse. So, mit dieser Seite gehen sie also online. Und sie ist sofort wieder offline. Auf Tagesschau stand dann mit den 20.000 Zugriffen pro Stunde was also fünfeinhalb pro Sekunde sind. Es ist nicht klargekommen. Ja, also ich würde sagen, also unser Admin sagte, wenn man einen Apache out of the box nimmt, ohne irgendwelche weiteren Caching oder sonst was, mit der Standard-Config, dann schafft er das eigentlich gerade so. Das heißt, man muss eigentlich schon aktiv das Ding nochmal fehl konfigurieren, dass er bei fünf Zugriffen pro Sekunde...
Daraufhin wurde es dann sozusagen gleich wieder eingestellt. Genau, wurde direkt wieder eingestellt. Ja, kann ja nicht sein, dass es so viele Leute gleichzeitig interessiert. Wir haben gedacht, da kommt jetzt, wie das halt in einer normalen Behörde auch ist, alle paar Minuten ein neuer Gast.
Der stellt sich auf und wird aufgerufen.
Haben sie das Formular ausgefilzt? Welches Formular? Haben sie eine Nummer gezogen?
Also...
Wir sind schon wieder total gehässig. So, jetzt haben sie offensichtlich noch das Häkchen bei Caching gesetzt und die Seite funktioniert. Und jetzt gibt es aber eine breite Kritik an dieser Veröffentlichung, wo gesagt wird, durch diese komische Deutschland-Lizenz begibt man die Leute wieder in so eine rechtliche Grauzone. Und außerdem gibt es dann noch so eine Einschränkung. Ja, weil es eben nicht Creative Commons ist, wo es einfach mal eine klare Lizenz gibt, die einfach standardisiert ist, wo man einfach weiß, wo man auch jahrelang durchdiskutiert wurde und wo man etwa weiß, woran man ist. Genau, wo man weiß, was man darf und was nicht. Und da gibt es jetzt irgendwie so eine, das ist echt ganz cool, wenn du da auf diese Lizenz kriegst, dann landest du wirklich bei diesem GitHub-Ding für die Deutschland-Lizenz. Und da steht dann irgendwie hier Deutschland-Lizenz. Und das soll ungefähr so etwas wie CC-Buy sein, aber heißt eben Deutschland-Lizenz. Und dann gibt es noch irgendwie so eine Non-Commercial-Lizenz. Und das wird natürlich dann auch von den Open-Data-Aktivisten durchaus kritisiert, weil dieser Non-Commercial-Teil ja dann schon wieder die komplette Nutzung stark einschränkt. Also die größte Hoffnung wäre natürlich, dass da Apps geschrieben werden, die diese Daten visualisieren oder so. Und wenn du da so eine Non-Commercial dran hast, dann kannst du jedem, der da irgendwas mitmacht, direkt wieder kommerzielles Interesse unterstellen. Und wenn jetzt unsere Freunde von Open Data City sich da irgendwas nehmen wollen würden, da ist ein Häkchen dran, Non-Commercial, dann könnten sie es halt schon wieder vergessen.
Also es geht ja eigentlich auch gerade darum, unter anderem die Wirtschaft auch damit in Wallungen zu kriegen. So ist es, ja.
Das war die Argumentation, ja. Und da wird also gesagt, ok, gab es dann eine große Protestseite mit sieben Punkten, wo also im Kern diese beiden Sachen kritisiert werden auf die zehn Prinzipien für offene Daten, der Open Knowledge Foundation verlinkt wird, die da also nicht gegeben sind, dass man außerdem fordert, dass die Behörden da verpflichtet werden, ihre Daten hinzugeben.
Also es sind nicht nur die Prinzipien der Open Knowledge Foundation, es ist auch eine Aktion gewesen. Also die hat sich da explizit zu ausgesprochen.
Diese Prinzipien gab es schon vorher. Und diese Aktion, da muss ich jetzt ganz kurz schauen, da haben alle möglichen Leute unterschrieben. Das ist so ein klassisches, wir sind alle dabei, so mit 12 Erstunterzeichnern. Unter anderem dann zum Beispiel der Dodger, den wir auch schon mal zum Hamburger Transparenzgesetz in der Sendung hatten, dann Open Data Network und Erstunterzeichner Open Knowledge Foundation Deutschland, der Daniel Dietrich, die jetzt alles kritisieren. Das klingt beim ersten Lesen natürlich nach Details, weil man natürlich sagen könnte, man könnte erst mal froh sein, dass es überhaupt Daten gibt, aber da steckt der Teufel dann tatsächlich auch im Detail, was also diese Lizenzen angeht. Das Ganze riecht so ein bisschen nach hier, wir haben Tausende von Daten da jetzt online gestellt und es ist relativ klar, dass diese Zahl Tausend irgendwie da offensichtlich auch eine Rolle gespielt hat, dass da also viel Daten bei sind, die vielleicht jetzt nicht so nutznützig sind. Man wünscht sich halt irgendwie, dass es eine erkennbare Ausrichtung gibt, dass wertvolle und nützliche Daten priorisiert werden bei der Veröffentlichung, dass man auf diese einschränkenden Lizenzen verzichtet, dass man also verpflichtet, Sachen zu veröffentlichen. Ferner wird dann gefordert, dass so noch in Marketing und Kommunikation investiert wird, um diese Plattform auch tatsächlich zu etablieren und so eine Art unabhängige Clearing-Stelle eingerichtet werden soll, die dann Weisungen und Rügen zur Veröffentlichung von Daten erteilen kann. Das wäre also im Prinzip so etwas wie frag den Staat, nur dann auch wirklich vom Staat selber unterhalten, um also wirklich eine Open-Data-Initiative zu haben und nicht nur so eine Nullnummer. Das heißt, Fazit ist also von Seiten der geschätzten Open-Data-Aktivisten ein netter, vorsichtiger Schritt in die richtige Richtung und jetzt mal bitte auch durchziehen. Also nicht nur den kleinen Zeh ins kalte Wasser halten, sondern wirklich mal reinspringen und ein paar Bahnen schwimmen.
Nachvollziehbar. Es ist halt wirklich die Frage, mir ist das ehrlich gesagt komplett entgangen, hier mit dem GovData-Ding. Aber wenn da jetzt letzten Endes das Bundesministerium für Inneres dahinter steckt, dann ist das ja dann im Prinzip eigentlich der erste wirkliche C, der hier ins Wasser gehalten wird, mal ernsthaft. Ja, also ich meine, zumindest tun sie so, als wäre es ernsthaft. Und gegebenenfalls haben sie ein paar Sachen noch übersehen oder sie haben vielleicht auch ein paar Sachen noch nicht so unbedingt sehen wollen oder waren nicht darüber bewusst, sind es nicht gewohnt, dass Webseiten, die sie veröffentlichen, dann auch tatsächlich von irgendjemanden gelesen und benutzt werden. Naja, ist ja auch häufig so, dass auch mal irgendwelche Sachen angekündigt werden und dann haben wir dann eine Webseite, was wollen sie denn so? Dann klickt da die Presse nachmittags drauf rum und danach interessiert es keinen Menschen mehr. Das haben wir ja wirklich tausendmal gehabt. Das ist natürlich jetzt hier was ganz anderes.
Ich warte auf das nächste Thema, denn es geht weiter.
Ja, okay, dann machen wir doch weiter mit dem nächsten Thema.
Spannend wird es nämlich. Also einerseits haben wir dieses Bundesinnenministerium, was also sagt, wir machen jetzt hier einen auf Open Data, mit dem Punkt und haben da irgendwie unsere eigene Lizenz geschrieben, weil wir nicht Creative Commons Lizenzen haben wollen. Andererseits kommt dann eine Anfrage der Linken an das Bundesinnenministerium zurück, in der das Bundesinnenministerium zugibt, eine Software entwickeln zu lassen, um Urheberrechtsverletzungen geschützter Werke der Verwaltung auf die Spur kommen zu können. Der Verwaltung. Da fragt man sich erstmal, was ist das? Offensichtlich ist es so, die Verwaltungen lizensieren teilweise auch irgendetwas, was sie produziert haben. Teil dieser Anfrage war auch, was sie damit für Einnahmen machen. Das BKA, das sind jetzt Jahreseinnahmen, die ich da mal rausgesucht habe, das BKA kriegt also 129 Euro Lizenzkosten im Jahr. 129 Euro? Die haben offensichtlich irgendeinen Datenzugriff lizenziert. Ich weiß nicht genau, was das ist. Die Bundespolizei 13 Euro. Aber dann zum Beispiel...
Haben sie auch die Verwaltungskosten dazu geschrieben?
Keine Ahnung, weiß der Geier, was das ist. Interessanter wird es dann bei dem Bundesamt für Kartografie und Geodesie, die also jährlich rund 181.000 Euro Lizenzeinnahmen haben von Daten, die sie unter Lizenz abgeben.
181.000 Euro, das ist das, was das Bundesamt... Aber das entfasst dann sozusagen nur jetzt den Federal-Level. Da sind die ganzen Landes nicht dabei.
Wie gesagt, es ist nicht weiter wirklich definiert, was... Knapp 370.000 Euro macht das Deutsche Institut für medizinische Dokumentation und Information mit geschützten Werken. Also quasi, wo sie etwas veröffentlichen und daran eine Urheberschaft geltend machen.
Wenn jemand benutzen will und dafür dann wiederum Lizenzen gezahlt.
Und die Gesellschaft für Kulturveranstaltungen des Bundes macht irgendwie 1,3 Millionen Euro Ausnutzungsrechten.
Aber das sind nicht Einnahmen für Künstler oder sowas?
Nutzungsrechte.
Gesellschaft für Kulturveranstaltungen des Bundes. Was es alles für Institutionen gibt.
Und die haben dann irgendwas und das muss man dann lizenzieren. Ich weiß auch nicht genau, was das ist. Stiftung Preußischer Kulturbesitz ist mir eher bekannt. Die kriegen sogar knapp 1,6 Millionen mit irgendwelchen Lizenzen. Sie geben irgendwas unter Lizenz ab. Weiß der Geier, was das ist?
Bildrechte, was weiß ich hier.
Vermutlich.
An ihrem Zeug und so weiter.
Interessant ist es, dass so, okay, also offensichtlich nehmen wir zur Kenntnis, die Bundesregierung hat Urheberschaft an Urheberrecht an bestimmten Dingen verkauft. Die ist ja auch in Ordnung, vermutlich. Haben aber jetzt 100.000 Euro bisher investiert in eine Software, die Urheberrechtsverletzungen auf die Spur kommen soll.
Wie viel?
100.000 Euro. Und die ist bisher nicht einsatzbereit.
Wo soll diese Software, diesen Werken auf die Spur kommen?
Ich vermute, dass sie im Internet unterwegs sein soll oder so. Und Petra Sitte von der Linkspartei, die die Anfrage gestellt hat, hat festgestellt, solche Software, Urheberrechtsverletzungs-Erkennungssoftware, gibt es ja schon auf dem Markt. Und entsprechende Probleme beim Datenschutz gibt es natürlich bei der Anwendung solcher Software. Und der Hersteller, den das Bundesinnenministerium da beauftragt hat, ist auch nicht bekannt. Also eine relativ komische Sache, die ich eigentlich auch nur deshalb erwähne, weil es in der gleichen Woche mit der Open Data Initiative auf den Tisch kam. Interessant. Also weiß der Geier, wenn wir für sowas Geld haben, ich denke, er ist der interessante Punkt. Das zeigt halt wirklich so, wie wenig jetzt die aktuelle Bundesregierung überhaupt irgendein Interesse hat, was in der Urheberrechts-Thema hat.
Ich meine, wenn man sich die Zahlen jetzt mal anschaut, also abgesehen von diesen 1,6 Millionen Euro für die Stiftung preußischer Kulturbesitz, wobei dieser Betrag unter Umständen, naja, also im Jahr, ja gut, aber ich weiß nicht genau, was die überhaupt für ein Budget haben.
Okay, das stimmt natürlich.
Ja, also das, wobei das sicherlich jetzt auch nicht so wenig ist. Das ist sicherlich kein ganz billiges Unterfangen, weil da gehört meines Wissens auch der ganze Betrieb und Erhalt der Gebäudestruktur, der Werke und so weiter, Lagerungen, alles dazu. Aber das ist ja dann sozusagen auch wieder gegenzurechnen mit Tourismus, Einfluss etc. Das würde ich jetzt gerne mal rauslassen. So diese Kulturveranstaltung des Bundes, das verwirrt mich auch so ein bisschen. Aber wenn ich mir anschaue, was das für Einnahmen sind im Bereich Kartografie. Ja, also da hätte ich ja jetzt wirklich andere Zahlen erwartet. Das bedeutet ja im Prinzip, dass der ganze Scheiß einfach zu wenig genutzt wird. Oder dass sie so lächerliche Lizenzbeträge haben, dass man sie im Prinzip auch genauso gut weglassen könnte. Ich meine 180.000 Euro. Ich meine, was soll das bitte ändern? Das ist sagen wir mal für ein Bundesetat von was auch immer ist das Pipifax. Und an der Stelle wäre es sicherlich zu überlegen, ob man nicht dann doch vielleicht mit einer freien Lizenzierung von vornherein besser weggekommen wäre. Weil die Zahl, die mir hier halt fehlt, ist, was ist der Verwaltungsaufwand? Also wie viele Leute müssen sich, gerade Bundespolizei 13 Euro, also wie viele Mitarbeiter müssen im Jahr da arbeiten, wie viele Tage, um diese Rechnungslegung von diesen 13 Euro herbeizuführen? Das ist bestimmt irgendwie ein Vielfaches von dem. Und ich glaube auch, dass BKA kriegt die 129 Euro Einnahmen nicht mit 129 Euro Verwaltungsgebühren abgedeckt.
Ich finde es schön, dass es 129 sind.
Warum nicht 129,99? Warum nicht 129A?
129.
129 A Euro. Na ja gut. War's das zu dem Thema? Ja, also falls jemand da Erkenntnisse hat, über diese Software, oder was die kann, oder was auch immer, oder vielleicht auch über diesen Verwaltungsaufwand, da würden wir gerne nochmal ein Addendum nachreichen.
Ja, ich komm da aber nicht so ganz mit, klar. Es ist interessant.
Schauen wir auf das Weltgeschehen, das gibt's ja auch noch. Wir erinnern uns, da gab's ja diverse Kämpfe auf internationaler Ebene, wo wir auch schon immer davon ausgegangen sind, dass das jetzt nicht so das letzte Lied war. Wie hieß nochmal die Ursprungsabkürzung?
Cyber Intelligence Sharing and Protection Act.
CISPA, nee, ich meine vor CISPA.
Save Online Piracy Act. Save Online Piracy Act, sehr schön.
Genau, CISPA war halt in den USA so ein Flop wie hier ACTA. Und dann hatten wir auch, glaube ich, Logbuch Netzpolitik berichtete, sozusagen so CISPA als so das Nachfolgeakronym schon auf dem Zeiger. Was gibt es denn da Neues?
Also bei CISPA ging es dann um das Urheberrecht. Und bei CISPA ging es dann um Cybercrime. Da sollte es also darum gehen, dass die Firmen irgendwie Cybercrime, Bedrohungsszenarien, Informationen sammeln. Zum Beispiel auch private Kommunikation ihrer Nutzer. Und diese dann der US-Regierung ohne Durchsuchungsbeschluss mitteilt. Unter anderem, indem es sie an die NSA, National Security Agency, sendet. Das war jetzt im letzten Anlauf so gewesen, dass dieser Vorschlag aus dem House of Representatives kam, dort auch angenommen wurde, jedoch im Senat glücklicherweise dann scheiterte. Und es auch schon so war, dass dem Obama, dem Präsidenten, angeraten wurde, das unter Umständen sogar zu wehtolen, dieses Gesetz. Das ist ja ein massiver Eingriff in die Privatsphäre dargestellt. Sicherlich wäre das sehr im Sinne von Herrn Maurer, der ja ungefähr genauso etwas fordert. Spannend ist, das wird jetzt einfach wieder vorgelegt. Sie haben, so steht es bei der IFF geschrieben, das ganze Ding, obwohl es abgelehnt wurde, jetzt wieder eingebracht. Mir ist nicht ganz klar, ob so etwas geht. Man wundert sich ja sowieso. In den letzten Folgen wundern wir uns ja tatsächlich über die...
Der Laie staunt. Auf jeden Fall haben alle den Mund offen.
Ich wundere mich. Das ist also in den USA zu erwarten, dass das einfach noch mal wieder diskutiert wird.
In Deutschland ist aber auch noch was passiert.
Ja, in Deutschland gibt es endlich ein bisschen Bewegung in dem Bereich der Netzneutralität. Und zwar hat der Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverband Vodafone für die Werbung, für den Tarif REDM abmahnen lassen. Abgemahnt. Und zwar ist es dieser REDM-Tarif, der auch von einer Kampagne der digitalen Gesellschaft da so herausgegriffen wurde, in dem gesagt wird, das wäre der ideale Tarif für unbegrenztes Telefonieren und Surfen, hat aber dann Einschränkungen im Bereich Peer-to-Peer, Voice-over-IP und Instant-Messaging. Also drei zentrale Protokolle und Funktionen der Internetnutzung sind da also ausgeschlossen. Das heißt, relativ offensichtliche Verletzung der Netzneutralität und zwar auch eine relativ ausführliche, eine tiefgreifende. Und diese Information ist natürlich irgendwie, was weiß ich, eben klein gedruckt auf Seite 8, wie das sich so gehört. Und ja, jetzt haben sie also eine Abmahnung von der Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverband. Und Vodafone kann also jetzt diese Werbung ändern und eine Unterlassungserklärung abgeben. Ansonsten scheint es dann so, wie das so bei Abmahnungen üblich ist, dass es dann da auf dem Verfahren rausläuft. Also das ist ja die übliche Ablauf bei einer Abmahnung.
Da ist auf jeden Fall noch einiges in der Kriegskasse, glaube ich, bei Vodafone für solche Fälle.
Ja, das ist richtig. Aber spannend auf jeden Fall. Ich finde es auf jeden Fall richtig, den juristischen Weg dann auch einfach mal einzuleiten, statt sich sowas die ganze Zeit gefallen zu lassen.
Kommen wir zum letzten Punkt, zum Gossip.
Das ist eigentlich nur eine schöne Anekdote. Die will ich eigentlich auch nur, die will man einfach noch mal so mit geschildert haben. Christian Lindner, FDP-Politiker. Anfang Januar schreibt die Wirtschaftswoche, dass es irgendwie sehr viele Änderungen von einer IP-Adresse vorgenommen wurden an seinem Wikipedia-Eintrag. Und dass diese IP-Adresse eindeutig dem Düsseldorfer Landtag zugeordnet werden kann. Er schreibt dann, dass es offensichtlich so aussieht, als würden die Mitarbeiter oder er selber von Christian Lindner diesen Wikipedia-Eintrag versuchen zu schönen. Außerdem ging es ihnen dann wohl darum, zwei bestimmte Fakten aus der Wikipedia herauszubekommen, die Wikipedia als Quelle dienten. Also Wikipedia hat quasi Behauptungen dastehen gehabt, für die es als Beleg einen Online-Artikel gab. Und dann wurde Wikipedia aufgefordert, diese Informationen auf der Seite herauszunehmen. Und Wikipedia hat gesagt, solange dieser Zeitungsartikel online ist, geht er uns als Quelle und wir lassen diese. Dann ist das so. Dann hat er seine Anwälte dahin geschickt, diese Presseveröffentlichungen offline zu nehmen. Und jetzt schließlich vor wenigen Tagen dann auch den Artikel der Wirtschaftswoche, der über diese Praxis schreibt, offline zu nehmen. Und vom Handelsblatt wird dann gesagt, wir haben uns mit Herrn Lindner darauf verständigt, dass der Artikel nicht mehr weiterverbreitet werden soll. Weil er in drei Punkten angreifbar erschien. Die Entfernung, sagen sie dann, erfolgte ohne Anerkennung einer Rechtspflicht, gleichwohl rechtsverbindlich. Also das Handelsblatt hat offensichtlich irgendwo etwas stehen gehabt, was der Lindner dann anfechten konnte und womit er ihn dann juristisch drohen konnte. Und dann war natürlich interessant, welche Behauptung denn da so falsch sein könnte. Da haben also einige nachgefragt und die erhielten dann die Auskunft, dass es um die Menge der Änderungen am Lindner Wikipedia-Eintrag im Jahr 2012 gegangen sei. Und die Wirtschaftswoche hätte 500 geschrieben, aber es seien tatsächlich knapp weniger als 400 gewesen. Irgendso ein Detail, aber klar, mit sowas können sie sich dann auch dran kriegen. Und damit nicht genug, also wer jetzt diesen Artikel aufruft, der kriegt also ein 404. Und weiterhin schreiben diese Anwälte jetzt Seitenbetreiber an, die einen Link auf diesen Artikel haben. Also das ist wirklich Internetputzen. Du siehst erst mal zu, dass du Wikipedia sauberkriegst. Dafür musst du Presseartikel entfernen. Und dann schreibst du noch alle an, die auf diesen Presseartikel gelinkt haben.
Damit auch niemand irgendwie jemals... Und was ist mit archive.org? Sind diese Artikel dort archiviert? Dann könnte man ja auch darauf linken und dann könnte man das auch wieder in die Wikipedia reinnehmen.
Muss ich mal schauen. Ich habe den Artikel tatsächlich nicht mehr finden können. Ich habe es ja auch erst heute Morgen angeschaut. Interessant. Also so geht ja der Lindner vor und vermutlich, da wir das jetzt hier auf Ton gebannt haben, kriegen wir demnächst auch einen Brief, in dem dann also uns unterstellt wird, wir würden diesen nicht abrufbaren Artikel weiterverbreiten. Und deshalb müssten wir den Link löschen und eine Unterlassungserklärung zurückschicken. Also du links auf ein 404-Dokument und musst trotzdem Unterlassungserklärung unterschreiben und damit aufhören.
Was natürlich vollkommen absurd ist, dass man dafür was an die Meise kriegt, dass man irgendwo hinlinkt, wo nichts ist. Das ist doch wirklich absurd, oder?
Ja, es ist.
Aber das haben wahrscheinlich auch Leute wieder gemacht, weil sie sich dachten, was soll es?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ja, also ich finde da ja verschiedene Sachen, finde ich da ja wirklich jetzt ein bisschen fragwürdig in dem Zusammenhang. Also auf der einen Seite auch was die Wikipedia betrifft, deren Realität sich quasi aus Presseerzeugnissen da auch ausschließlich ableitet und das so als hoheitliche Sache annimmt. Ich meine, ich kann verstehen, Quellen wollen benannt werden. Man will da letztlich berichten über die Sachen, die eben nachvollziehbar sind. Aber hier, wo dieser Artikel ja schon mal da war, wo dieses Wissen ja auch da ist, dann zu sagen, das gibt es jetzt nicht mehr, weil der Artikel ist ja gelöscht worden. Aber es gab ihn ja mal und dieses Wissen liegt ja vor. Nämlich unter anderem auch in der Wikipedia, die sich da sozusagen auch wieder selbst als Quelle nennen können. Mit ihren Versionen, also das ist alles ein bisschen verdreht.
Ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher, was...
Also und natürlich auch die Medien selber. Ich meine, dass sie ihre eigenen Artikel offline nehmen. Meine Guter, denken sie wahrscheinlich auch ganz so, ja, was kümmert mich das Geschwätz von gestern? Der Artikel bringt jetzt hier eh keine neuen Hits mehr und kein Geld und so, ob wir den jetzt runternehmen oder in Ropfeld sagen, Melum.
Die Frage ist natürlich jetzt, gehen wir mal davon aus, dass der, wenn wir jetzt davon ausgehen, dass dieser Artikel halt nicht der Wahrheit entspricht. Also dann wäre es ja in der Tat sehr übel. Dann müsste man natürlich auch überlegen, inwiefern einem Menschen die Möglichkeit gegeben werden muss, so einer Falschbehauptung dann entgegenzutreten. Wäre ja auch mal eine interessante Frage. Aber es riecht ja in diesem Fall eher so danach, dass das, also ich meine, so viele Änderungen, immer nur eine Person in Wikipedia aus einem Düsseldorfer Landtag.
Netzputzer in Aktion.
Ja, ich meine, diese Berichterstattung wird ja jetzt nicht mehr loswerden.
Das hoffen wir auch. Unser Artikel bleibt nämlich auf jeden Fall online.
Unser Artikel bleibt online und der Link auf archive.org/details/christian Lindner zensiert, den lassen wir auch bestehen. Da ist der Artikel als Kopierpaste von in der Open Source Collection.
Das ist jetzt tatsächlich dieser HB Handelsblatt-Artikel, oder was?
Das ist jetzt irgendwie so eine Art Kopierpaste. Und die Wayback Machine ist leider nicht in der Lage, uns den, ah doch, einen Snapshot vom 9.
Februar.
Ja, Seite nicht gefunden.
Naja, wir arbeiten dran.
Ja, also zumindest der Wortlaut des Artikels ist gegeben. So, erstmal hier alles sichern.
Kann man das ja in der Wikipedia dann auch gleich wieder eintragen. Ansonsten könnt ihr gerne auf Logbuch Netzpolitik linken. Wir lassen uns hier auch nicht so schnell weg mahnen.
Ich bin mal gespannt. Ich werde jetzt erstmal ein bisschen was auf Wikipedia über Christian Lindner schreiben. Christian Lindner. Nee, ach, keine Ahnung. Es ist halt mal interessant zu sehen, also von beiden Seiten aus. Diese Wikipedia-Pflege ist immer der erste Treffer zu allem, was da drin steht. Wenn da was Falsches drin steht, ist er sicherlich bei weitem nicht der erste Politiker, der sich mit so was auseinandersetzt, mit vermeintlichen Fehlinformationen auf Wikipedia. Und das ist eine große Herausforderung für dieses System Wikipedia. Und gleichzeitig sieht man also daran, wie schwierig das für Menschen sein kann, so etwas wieder loszuwerden. Interessantes Phänomen.
Ja, weitere interessante Phänomene gibt es dann in der nächsten Woche, weil wir sind jetzt hier durch mit unserem Programm, oder?
Wir sind durch, ich bin nächste Woche aber nicht da. Werden wir sehen, wer mich da vertritt.
Okay, ich bin gespannt.
Ich auch.
Ja, aber dann in zwei Wochen wieder.
In zwei Wochen wieder.
Ist klar.
Dann winken wir unseren Hörern und Hörerinnen und Freunden uns auf ein Wiedersehen.